it is early morning of the first tuesday
in november
this is an american city
a city that is not very large
not very rich
not very old
it is situated in the western part of
the united states
in california
its name is riverton
the woman in the car is mrs dawson one
of riverton's fifteen thousand residents
she is principal of public school number
two
but today there will be no classes held
here
for this is election day
this classroom is one of the 130 000
places the country over
in which american citizens are going to
cast their votes today
this is the table where the voters names
will be checked
the locked ballot
box and the polling booth
here it is in the privacy of this
curtain space that the american voters
every four years
on the first tuesday after the first
monday in november choose their national
government
here come mrs dawson's colleagues on the
election board of riverton's seventh
precinct each representing one of the
major political parties
mr schwartz is a republican who works
for the streetcar company
mrs abernathy is a housewife and a
democrat mrs dawson is chairman
they've all known one another for years
first they remove the last traces of
their campaign activities
their party buttons
then they take the oath
defend the constitution of the united
states of america and perform your
duties members of the election brought
the best of your ability so help you god
i do
i do
this makes them responsible for seeing
that the voting here today takes place
according to the laws of the land
and now the polls are open
here comes the first voter
no wonder he's first he's been up since
four o'clock delivering milk
oh yeah good morning
everybody top line you're the very first
one right on the dock i always like to
vote early give the republicans a
temporary lead
here's your ballot though
that's as far as we can go
remember this is a secret vote
no one ever sees another person mark his
ballot
however if we did have miraculous powers
and if we were able just this once to
follow bill johnson
this is what we'd see
he votes first for the chief executives
the president and vice president of the
united states
next he votes for a senator from his
state
then a representative from his district
this man is casting his vote for a
government of his own choosing under the
constitution of the united states
this is the way it's set up
there are three branches of the united
states government
the executive branch or president
the legislative branch or congress
and the judicial branch or supreme court
the duties of each branch are
established in the constitution
let's see how they work
the president is the executive head of
the nation
he initiates all important policies
such as treaties with other governments
and the conduct of national affairs
he is the commander-in-chief of the army
and the navy
an important consideration in a wartime
election the vice president is the
president's legal successor
the president keeps him informed on
matters of state and policy
the vice president by custom sits as a
member of the president's cabinet
the cabinet members are the heads of the
executive departments of the government
such as the state department war
department treasury department
department of the interior of labor
commerce and so on
the cabinet advises the president on
matters of policy
the powers of the president and his
helpers are limited
for this is a government not of men
but of laws based upon the constitution
congress makes the laws
it is a parliament which unlike many
democratic parliaments has no direct
connection with the executive branch
this branch of the government is made up
of two houses
the senate and the house of
a
representatives
may originate in either house
but must be approved by both of them
when a bill is passed by both houses it
is sent to the president
if the president also approves the bill
he signs it
it then becomes law
president may veto a bill passed by the
congress
but congress may still by a two-thirds
majority make the bill law
although the chief responsibility of
congress is that of making laws
certain other responsibilities are
delegated to the two houses
in the senate or upper house as it is
called
each of the 48 states in the nation is
represented by two elected members
making a total membership of 96
small states and large have equal
representation in the senate
the senate has two important functions
aside from its law making duties
to pass on important presidential
appointments
and to approve or reject all treaties
with other nations initiated by the
president
when a treaty is under consideration the
members of the senate express their
opinions
either of approval or of disapproval
and then a vote is taken
if two-thirds of the senate approves of
the treaty it is in effect
in the house of representatives or lower
house
each of the 48 states is represented in
proportion to its population
the more populous of the states have the
greater number of members in the house
of representatives
all measures dealing with the
appropriation of money for the nation's
use originate and are controlled in the
lower house
the money appropriated is turned over to
the president for expenditure
and the president with the aid of the
cabinet
spends the money in the manner decided
upon by the congress
whether it be for purposes of peace or
of war
although the congress of the united
states makes the laws of the land its
powers are also limited by the
constitution
as a check on both executive and
legislative branches of the government
there is a third branch the judicial
the supreme court whose members are
appointed for life by the president
the supreme court protects the
constitution from violation by
congressional laws or executive orders
the three branches
executive legislative
and judicial
each with some power
none with all the power
check and balance each other in the
manner intended by the framers of the
constitution
so that the ultimate power rests always
in the hands of the voter bill johnson
having voted for a federal government he
must also choose a governor for his
state
members of the state assembly
county judges
all the minor officers and various
legislative amendments
when bill johnson has finished he has
elected an entire government from top to
bottom
that is if a majority of the voters
think the way he does about it
it's not only here in riverton that the
voting is heavy today
all over the country people are
conscious of the momentous issues facing
their nation and the world
this is their way of expressing their
conviction
of how and by whom these issues should
be met
the two major presidential candidates
vote like all the other citizens
one of them in new york city describes
himself as a lawyer
the other up in the country where his
home is gives his occupation as farmer
for those who cannot come to the polls
an absentee ballot is provided and the
voting is supervised by the local notary
this is the same kind of ballot that in
this wartime election is sent to members
of the armed forces at home and abroad
these ballots are returned to be counted
in their respective states
here in riverton the line grows longer
the citizens are following the
constitutional provision that elections
are held on schedule rain or shine panic
or prosperity peace or war
that chalk on his sleeve is part of
yesterday's history lesson
when mrs dawson reminded her pupils of
two other memorable elections
in 1864 with the nation in the throes of
a civil war abraham lincoln one of
america's greatest presidents was
opposed in a bitter campaign by one of
his own generals
the people chose to re-elect mr lincoln
in 1916 during the first world war an
election was held
and now again in 1944
early in the summer nominating
conventions are held
at these traditionally noisy political
jamborees
the chosen delegates of each major party
meet to select a candidate for the
presidency and the vice presidency of
the united states
now the candidates have been chosen
and the campaign is on
from president to local sheriff
for three months all through the late
summer and fall
wherever people come together issues and
men are discussed and argued about
some feel that this isn't all together a
good thing
that a lot of time and energy are wasted
this way
it may be
but that's the way americans like to do
it
they like to feel everybody has a right
to speak and is interested enough to do
it
even the small fry
every attempt is made by all parties to
influence the people's thinking
all over the country week after week 140
million citizens take part in the great
debate
business professional and civic groups
endorse one candidate or the other
for the first time in american history
organized labor takes an active part in
the campaign
radio plays a greater role than ever
time on the air is paid for by all
parties and distributed evenly among
them
giving the party an office no advantage
over its opponents it is estimated that
in the last days of the 1944 campaign
70 million americans heard the speeches
of the various candidates
now all that is over the heat and
excitement
the votes are cast and americans have
agreed to accept the will of the
majority whatever it may be
apparently even the younger generation
has declared peace
now the election board begins its last
duty the counting of the votes
the figures are checked and double
checked
then they are telephone to headquarters
hello
this is mrs dawson 7th precinct ready to
report
from coast to coast precinct by precinct
city by city state by state the results
are recorded
all over america tonight the people are
waiting to learn whom they have chosen
to govern them for the next four years
towards midnight the final results are
announced
a nation of 140 million has elected a
government